كشف مبعوث الامم المتحده الى اليمن
اسماعيل ولد الشيخ احمد عن محاولات للتوصل
الى هدنه قبل حلول شهر رمضان تمهيدا
لاستئناف المحادثات وقد اكدت الحكومه
اليمنيه حرصها على السلام ودعت المبعوثه
الدوليه لحث الحوثيين وصالح على الالتزام
بالمرجعيات والقواعد المتفق
عليها
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كان هذا خبر
حلقتنا ونناقش فيما وراءه ما هي فرص نجاح
مساعي اعلان وقف لاطلاق النار في اليمن
قبل حلول شهر رمضان المبارك وهل تعزز
التحركات الراهنه جهود احياء عمليه السلام
بعد جمودها
الطويل
هل يشهد شهر رمضان المبارك وقفا لاطلاق
النار بين المتحاربين في اليمن وهل تغتنم
اطراف الازمه الفرصه للعوده الى طاولات
التفاوض
والتشاور مثل هذه التساؤلات تطرح اليوم
بعد تصريحات لمبعوث الامم المتحده الى
اليمن اسماعيل ولد الشيخ احمد بشان سن
هدنه قبل نهايه الشهر الجاري تمهيدا
لاجراء جوله جديده من الحوار ابدت الحكومه
الكويتيه استعدادها لاحتضانها في حال وجود
صيغه لانهاء الازمه اليمنيه ما لا شك فيه
ان تطورات محليه واقليميه وعلى صعيد
الاطراف الدوليه المهتمه بالشان اليمني قد
سجلت في الفتره الاخيره تقرير زياد
بركات لا يبتلى اليمن بالحرب فحسب فهناك
ما هو اسوا انه الكوليرا في زمن الحرب
تجتاح صنعاء وتفتك بنحو
مواطنا انه ناقوس الخطر يدق قبيل رمضان
فالازم ليست صحيه فقط بل نتاج اخرى اكبر
سياسيه واخذه بالتفاقم منذ استولى
الحوثيون على صنعاء في ايلول سبتمبر من
عام
2014 ولا حل جذريا لماس اليمنيين سو بوقف
الحرب او على الاقل بهد انسانيه ولو مؤقته
وهذا ما يقترحه اخيرا اسماعيل ولشيخ احمد
وقف لاطلاق النار قبيل الشهر الفضيل
تمهيدا لاستئناف محادثات السلام ووقف
العمليات العسكريه في اتجاه ميناء الحديده
يقدم وزير الخارجيه اليمني تفاصيل اكثر
يقول ان مقترحه للشيخ احمد يقوم على فكره
تحريك الجمود من خلال انسحاب الحوثيين من
الحديده لا من صنعاء ووضع مينائها تحت
سيطره الشرعيه بما يوفر ميزه بالغه
الاهميه تحتاجها البلاد باسرها ومناطقها
المنكوبه تحديدا وهي ضمان تدفق المساعدات
الانسانيه الى اليمن ترحب الشرعيه ضمنا
بمقترح الموفد الدولي ويحدث هذا بينما
يبدا رئيس الوزراء احمد بن دغر زياره الى
برلين هناك يجري حوار غير رسمي بين ممثلين
عن الشرعيه والحوثيين برعايه الخارجيه
الالمانيه وذاك مسار موازن يعتقد انه اقرب
الى جس النبض منه الى مشروع حل قد ترعاه
المانيا وهو ما المحت اليه المستشاره
انجلا ميركل خلال زيارتها للسعوديه فثم
رغبه في القيام بدور ما ولو من خلف الستار
لحل ازمه تستفحل سياسيا
وانسانيا ويعتقد ان الصراع في اليمن قد
يكون مقبلا على انعطافات حاسمه ربما تتضح
ملامحها خلال زياره ترامب لسعود الاسبوع
المقبل والتي تقوم وفقا لاركان الاداره
الامريكيه على ضرب اذرع ايران في المنطقه
ماقد يفسر تحركات الروسيه للدخول على خط
الحلول المقترحه والى ان يحدث هذا او بعضه
ثمه ضحايا يسقطون جوعا او بالكره ومن لم
يسقط بالاثنين سقط بالسلاح وهو كثير هناك
ولا يتوقف تدفقه ولا استخدامه منذ سنين
عددا لمناقشه موضوع حلقتنا هذه معنا من
الرياض الناشط السياسي محمد ناجي الاو عضو
الهيئه الوطنيه للرقابه على تنفيذ مخرجات
الحوار الوطني ومن لندن ينضم الينا الكاتب
والباحث السياسي اليمني محمد جميح وابدا
معك سيد محمد ناجي علاو فجاه بتنا امام
محاولات لابرام هدنه لاستئناف المحادثات
اليمنيه ما الذي استجد عند الموفد الدولي
اسماعيل ولد الشيخ
احمد بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم مساء الخير
لك ولضيوفك مسا الكرام وساده
المشاهدين الحقيقه بان وظيفه الا الامم
المتحده دائما ودوما تسعى بالتاكيد لمثل
هذه الهدن الانسانيه كما تسمى
و تسعى بالتاكيد لجلب المتحاربين على
طاوله المفاوضات هذه وظيفتها وبدونها لا
وظيفه
ا تجربتنا عندما كنا في الكويت وكان ذلك
ايضا قبل رمضان وكان الضغط على ان رمضان
اتي وله قدسيته نعم وبالتالي السعي لايجاد
اي هدنه وتم الاتفاق في ظهر الجنوب في حين
كما تعلمون بين الحوثيين وبين المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وشكلت لجان للتهدئه في
هذا الصدد ولكن للاسف الشديد لكن لكن يبدو
تبدو تبدو الامور اليوم سيد علاو تبدو
الامور اليوم مختلفه شيئا ما صحيح الحديث
عن هدنه في شهر رمضان نتيجه لقدس هذا
الشهر المبارك لكن هناك محاوله او عمل
لاست لاستئناف المحادثات
هناك دول كالكويت مثلا تتحدث او تبدي
استعدادها ل احتضان هذه المحادثات وهناك
ايضا حوارات غير رسميه تجري في المانيا
اذا الجو العام كله ربما يكون مهيئا من
هنا كان
السؤال نعم الجو العام
و نحن حقيقه نشكر حرص الجميع على
وقف يعني زيف الدم اليمني وعلى ايجاد حل
لهذه المشكله الشائكه لكن انا شخصيا لست
متفائلا كثيرا باعتبار ان الاطراف ما زالت
لها رهاناتها وتراهن على الوقت وخاص خاصه
بان المشاريع مختلفه تماما هناك مشروع
وطني تتبنى الشرعيه يتبنى مخرجات الحوار
وهناك مشروع سلالي امامي يريد ان يعيد
التاريخ الى الوراء ويريد مشروعه الخاص
ضمن المشروع الايراني في المنطقه يعني هو
مرتهن ايضا لاوراق خارجيه واسعه وهناك
ايضا قوى التحالف التي شاركت بالدم
وبالقتل مع الشرعيه ولها مخاوفها ايضا من
هذا الجانب ابقى معي ماذا اقول ان المسائل
متشابكه ام نعم ابقى معي س سانتقل الى
صنعاء عبر الهاتف مع الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي عبد الوهاب الشرفي سيد عبد الوهاب
المشروع المطروح اليوم اي في بعض النقاط
التي اصبحت واضحه منها مقترحات مثلا تسليم
الحوثيين للحديده مدينه وميناء تسليمها ان
كان للامم المتحده او للشرعيه كبدايه
لاستئناف المحادثات وايضا ل هدنه هل
الحوثيون ربما يقبلون بهذا
المقترح مساء الخير لك ولضيفك الكريمين
وساده المشاهدين الاكارم هو بالطبع هذا
المقترح هو غريب يعني في
الاخير بدات مقايضه على مستوى جبهات هذا
الامر يعني فيه ارضاء مباشر للرغبه
السعوديه على حساب العمليه السياسيه التي
تتم في البلد في الاخير هناك عمليه سياسيه
كان يفترض ان يتم الدفع
باتجاهها وليس التحول الى يعني تحقيق
نتائج التحالف يسعى لتحقيقها من خلال
حديثه او ينوي تحقيقها عن طريق ما يعرف
بمعركه الحديده التي يتم التجهيز لها وهو
يريد الان
ان ان يصل الى النتيجه بدون قتال طبعا هذا
الامر ميناء الحديده اي نقطه اخرى في من
من المناطق التي حولها النزاع تظل المساله
متعلقه بالوصول الى تسويه سياسيه يتم بعد
ذلك ترجمتها على مختلف المواقع سواء ميناء
الحديده او غيره وادخاله في ظل لكن الحديث
سيد عبد الوهاب سيد سيد عبد الوهاب الحديث
عن هذه المقترحات انما ياتي من ضمن سله
كامله ربما يتحدث عنها اسماعيل ول شيخ
احمد تبدا بوقف اطلاق النار او على الاقل
هدنه في شهر رمضان استئناف المحادثات
السياسيه هل الحوثيون يعني ليسوا في هذه
الاجواء او هم غير موافقين حتى الان عموما
على هذه الرؤيه التي طرحها اسماعيل ولدي
الشيخ
احمد ليست الاشكاليه في موقف الحوثيين
الاشكاليه في الاداء الذي يتم باتجاه
الوصول الى هدنه نحن لازلنا نعمل بنفس
الاسلوب الذي تم التوجه الى الهدن السابقه
به وال العمليه السياسيه والاعلاميه لا
اقل ولا اكثر لم يتم القيام باي تعديل في
في في الهيكليه المطلوبه لقيام حاله هدنه
فعليه على الارض واول ذلك الوصول الى لجان
محايده تشرف على وقف اطلاق النار لان هذه
النقطه هي النقطه التي ينطلق منها لافشال
وقف اطلاق النارو المحاولات السابقه اعتقد
انا اذا كان هناك توجه سليم وحقيقي باتجاه
وقف اطلاق نار لا يمانع على الاطلاق اطراف
صنعاء سواء انصار الله او المنصر الشعبي
العام او لنقول المجلس السياسي الذي بات
الان يمثل ال كلا يعترض على الاطلاق
والتجارب الماضيه هي ماثله ان مواقفهم
كانت ايجابيه بينما الطرف الاخر هو لا
يسير سيرا سويا وصولا للهدنه سيد محمد
جميح
يعني اذا نظرنا الى الحراك الذي
يتحرك في اطاره اسماعيل ولد الشيخ احمد
يبدو انه مختلف او على الاقل حتى اللحظه
ما زال بعيدا عما يفكر فيه الحوثيون في
صنعاء نعم بعد التحيه لك ولضيفك الكريمين
والمشاهدين هذا
صحيح الامم المتحده خلال الاسابيع الماضيه
كان هاجسها الاكبر ادخال المعونات
الانسانيه عن طريق ميناء الحديده والدفع
بتاخير او الغاء الترتيبات الحاليه
لاستعاره مدينه الحديده ومينائها او
ومينائها من الانقلابيين الى
الشرعيه تعمل قوات التحالف العربي طبعا
بالتوازي مع الحكومه الشرعيه على ان يكون
هناك حل عرضت الحكومه وقوات
التحالف في حينها على الامم المتحده كحل
لهذا الاشكال اشكال ان الحكومه الشر يه
تتهم الانقلابيين باستخدام الحديده لتهريب
السلاح واشكال ان الانقلابيين يقولون ان
الميناء محاصر وان الناس بحاجه الى معونات
انسانيه وضعوا حلا وسطا بان تتولى الامم
المتحده الاشراف على هذا الميناء من اجل
ان يضمن ان يكون الميناء انسانيا لادخال
المعونات الانسانيه وبالطبع العمليات
التجاريه لضخ المواد الغذائيه للناس لكن
للاسف الشديد الامم المتحده رفضت في حينها
متعلله بالقول بان لا تملك الصلاحيات وليس
الان مطروح الامر من جديد ما الذي ما الذي
تغير او
استجد الذي استجد ان هذه هذه هذه الاجواء
التي كانت سائده في الامم المتحده هي التي
افرزت الخطه الجديده وانا في تصوري انها
خطه انسانيه بمعزل او قد تكون على علاقه
واهيه بالجانب السياسي لكن الجانب المهم
في هذه الخطه هو الجانب الانساني الامم
المتحده تريد ان تدخل مواد اغ وطبيه الى
البلاد عن طريق الميناء وبالتالي بدلا من
ان تقتحم قوات الحكومه الشرعيه بتغطيه من
التحالف وندخل في معركه ربما تدمر فيها
المدينه ويتضرر المدنيون رعت الامم
المتحده عن طريق اسماعيل ولد الشيخ ان
يصار الى صيغه معينه تسلم بموجبها هذهه
المدينه بما انها لم تسلم للامم المتحده
تسلم للحكومه الشرعيه سلما مع ضمان من
الحكومه الشرعيه ان تتدفق كل المعونات
الانسانيه وا ايضا ان يعاد تفعيل الميناء
لصالح الناس في الداخل اليمني لكن هذا ليس
السؤال هذه هي الخطه انما السؤال هل سيقبل
الحوثيون بالتاكيد الحوثيون لن يقبلوا
بذلك لانهم بالنسبه لهم ميناء الحديده هو
الرئه التي يتنفسون منها سلاحا وذخيره وهو
الرئه الذي يتنفسون التي يتنفسون منها
ايضا عن طريق المهربات ل المحروقات ايرادا
وتصديرا وبالتالي اعتقد ان هذه الهدنه
المقترحه هيعم من اجل الوضع الانساني
بمعزل عن الجانب السياسي وان كانت من وجهه
نظر المبعوث الدولي ستمهد للدخول في
الجانب السياسي لان الانتقال من تس الى تس
الحديده يعني الانتقال من التركيز على
الجانب السياسي الى الجانب الانساني
الجانب هذا الجانب السياسي هو موضوع
نقاشنا في الجزء الثاني من هذه الحلقه
فاصل مشاهدينا بعده نكون امام امكانيه
استئناف المحادثات اليمنيه بعد اكثر من
تسعه اشهر من الجمود ابقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا في هذه
الحلقه التي تناقش فرص نجاح اقتراح
المبعوث الدولي الى اليمن وقف اطلاق النار
في شهر رمضان مع تسليم ميناء الحديده
للحكومه الشرعيه واعود الى ضيفي من الرياض
محمد ناجي علاو سيد
محمد قبل الفاصل سيد جميح من لندن استبعد
ان
يكون ان ان يكون ما هو مطروح الان هو من
ضمن سياق سياسي عام انما هو منفصل وله
علاقه باعتبارات انسانيه محضه هل تفصل ما
يجري اليوم عن الاجواء السياسيه العامه
المحيطه سيد عال ا سيد الجليل نعم نعم
تفضل لا يمكن فصل
الجانب السياسي عن الجوانب
عن ت داعيه الحرب الاخرى وهي طبعا الجانب
الانساني بالدرجه الاولى ذلك ان مساله
التدفق المواد الغذائيه والبضائع
ميناء الحديده مفتوح وتتدفق المساعده
الانسانيه وتذهب الى صنعاء ثم يوزع توزع
من صنعاء الى المناطق الشرعيه يعني
المساله معكوسه المناطق الشرعيه لا توجد
لديها اغاثه انسانيه تاتي مباشره الى
ميناء عدن بهذا المعنى وبالتالي ليس صحيحا
على اطلاق على الاطلاق كما ذكر الاستاذ
محمد جميح او دكتور محمد جميح ان ميناء
الحديده مغلق ليس
مغلقا المساعده الانسانيه تاتي عبره من
خلال منظمات الامم المتحده التجاره تاتي
عبره لكن مساله
ا ان هناك معركه قادمه ضمن طبيعه الصراع
والساعي لتجنب هذه المعركه
و يعني تضرر المدنيين
والمدينه الحقيقه هو جانب انساني نبيل لكن
هل يقبله الحوثيين هذه مساله متصله بقضيه
حساباتهم العسكريه والسياسيه اذا لا
انفصال بين المسالتين وانا مثل ما قال
الاستاذ عبد الوهاب الشرفي مع محاوله
تلميع الجانب الذي هو منه ا يعني فشلت
حقيقه كل الهدن السابقه لان الاليات على
الارض ليست صادقه حتى قضيه اللجان
المحايده الذي يتحدث عنها ا في المره
السابقه بعد اتفاق ظهران الجنوب كانت
اللجان من الطرفين والطرفين بالضروره
منحازين لبعض للطرف الذي عينه من اين
سناتي بهذه اللجان المحايده من المريخ ما
ادري الحقيقه المساله معقده جدا والقضيه
متصله بمساله التوازن الذي ما زال الى حد
ما يعتقد الحوثيين انه في مصلحتهم وان
الوقت ايضا يخدمهم وان المساله الانسانيه
التي يلعبون عليها المدينه والحرص عليها
ترص على مدينه تعز التي تقصفها وتقصف
اسواقها كل يوم الره هذه التي انتشرت
نتيجه عدم قدرتكم على تنظيف المدينه على
تنظيف
موتكم بانكم يعني اقصد اي نعم دعني دعني
اسال سيد عبد الوهاب الشرفي من صنعاء سيد
عبد الوهاب ما هي الحسابات السياسيه
والعسكريه اليوم التي ستتحكم بموقف
الحوثيين مما هو مطروح من امكانيه حصول
الهدنه ومن امكانيه استئناف المحادثات وما
بينهما لجهه تجنب معركه مناء
الحديده ساعر لك بدايه من قضيه ميناء
الحديده يجب اولا ان يكون هناك تفريق بين
قضيه المطالبه بتسليم ميناء الحديده هذا
الامر بطبيعته كما قلت لك سيكون مرفوضا
لان هناك حل يجب التوجه له هو الحل
السياسي لكن قضيه التعاون في جانب تجنيب
المدنيين الاضرار التي ينوي التحالف
الذهاب اليها عن طريق وجود الامم المتحده
ضمن الاشراف على الدور الانساني وعلى
الاغاثات الانسانيه هذا الامر اتوقع انا
ان اطراف صنعاء ستجاوب معه وفي ظل مواصفات
خاصه يمكن ان يقوم لكن تسليم الميناء
بالطبع هذا الامر هو نتيجه معركه وليس
نتيجه يعني العمليه الانسانيه بالنسبه فقط
بالنسبه ل الاستاذ محمد هو عندما يتح حدث
عن اللجان المشتركه عليه ان لا يخلط بين
المشتركه وبين المحايده في الاخير الذهاب
الى اللجان المشتركه هو كان لاجهاد اساسا
اللجان المحايده التي يجب ان التي كانت
تفك عليها بنهايه جنيف بنهايه جنيف 2
واللجان المحايده لا تاتي من المريخ
بالامكان ان تاتي من دول محايده ومن الامم
المتحده تكون ضمن قوام اللجان ولا داعي
لتصوير المساله بانها مستحيله في الاخير
انا اعتقد انه
المتحكم في قضيه القتال او من عدمه هي
التحالف العربي هو الوحيد الذي اذا وجدت
عنده الاراده هو قادر بان يسمح لليمنيين
بان يذهبوا في اتفاق هدنه وفي اتفاق طيب
الى اي مدى يمكن لزياره ترامب الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وما يمكن ان تفرزه من
دعم ربما ينعكس على اكثر من
اي ساحه توتر في
المنطقه الى اي مدى هذا الامر يمكن ان
يشكل عامل ضغط وتراجع من قبل الحوثيين
وداعميهم
الاقليميين في الاخير هي زياره ترامب على
كل حال هي ذات تاثير مباشر على الملف
اليمني وغيره من الملفات على اعتبار ان
هناك الولايات المتحده هي تتحدث منذ وقت
مبكر بانها ستوسع مشاركتها للتحالف
السعودي في حربه العدوانيه على اليمن
ومعركه ميناء الحديده في صداره هذا الامر
وبالتالي المساله قد تكون اكثر اللحظات
هشاشه لانطلاق معركه الحديده اساسا زياره
ترامب على اعتبار ان الرجل عرف
بسلوكه الابتزاز وسيقبل الثمن من المملكه
وقد تنطلق المعركه في هذه اللحظه السياسيه
الهشه لكن في الاخير كما قلت لك واكده بان
اطراف صنعاء ليست هي المعين فيما يتعلق
بوقف اطلاق النار والذهاب الى ح سياسي
وانما المعيق هو عدم توفر الاراده
السياسيه لدى التحالف السعودي حتى اللحظه
طيب سيد محمد جميح ما رايك بما ذكره السيد
عبد الوهاب شرفي واضيف هنا سؤال لك ايضا
يتعلق بالتطور الجنوبي وازمه المجلس
الانتقالي الى اي مدى يمكن ايضا ان تشكل
عامل ضغط للذهاب الى حل هنا عامل ضغط على
الحكومه الشرعيه للذهاب
الى حلول مع الحوثيين
في يعني البدء وانا لم اقل ان الميناء كان
مغلقا كما ذكر الاستاذ محمد انما قلت ان
الحوثيين يقولون بانه محاصر والا فان
البضائع في العاصمه صنعاء تاتي عن طريق
هذا الميناء لكن بالنسبه ل بعض التعليقات
على ما ذكره الاستاذ عبد الوهاب من صنعاء
انا اعتقد انه لم يصدر عن اي طرف من اطراف
الشرعيه التصريحات الواضحه بنسب مرجعيات
الحوار الوطني يعني في الخطابات الاخيره
التي القيت من طرفي الانقلاب في الداخلي
يؤكدون على التملص عفوا والتخلص من
مرجعيات الحل يعني يرفضون القرار الدوري
الاخير يقولون انه لم يعد قائما يقولون
ايضا ان مخرجات الحوار الوطني لم تعد
ملزمه اما الحوثيون فانهم لا يؤمنون اصلا
بالمبادره الخليجيه وبالتالي هنا الاشكال
بينما الحكومه في كل بيان من بياناتها وفي
كل لقاء من لقاءاتها تؤكد على المرجعيات
ثلاث للحل التي تعارف عليها المجتمع
الدولي والاقليمي ووافقت عليها الاطراف
الداخليه بالنسبه للوضع في الجنوب انا
اعتقد انه القى بحجر اخرى في في دائره هذه
المياه وربما يلقي بعض التعقيدات فيما يخص
معسكر الشرعيه ذاته لكنه لا اتصور ان يكون
له اثر بالغ في عمليه الحل السياسي في
اليمن لان ما سيكون في الجنوب هو من ضمن
ما هو موجود ضمن الشرعيه لان القوى
الجنوبيه كانت يعني ولا زالت قوى مقاومه
لمد الحوثي ولانقلاب في الداخل وبالتالي
تعتبر لحد هذه اللحظه مكون من مكونات
الشرعيه انا في تصوري انه سيصار الى حل
ضمن مظله الشرعيه لهذا الموضوع ولا اتصور
ان يكون ذلك حجر عثره في اطار او في سبيل
الحل السياسي العقده في صنعاء وليست في
عددا في تصور اعود اعود من جديد الى السيد
علاو من الرياض امام ما سمعناه سيد علاو
هل لديك نوع من التفاؤل بامكانيه نجاح اي
فرص استئناف المحادثات
و فرص ابرام هدنه في شهر
رمضان سيدي اتمنى ان تبرم هدنه لكن وان
تصمد هذه الهدنه بالحزاز ا ابرامها ق زايد
الطرفين في المساله بغض النظر عن
المصداقيه هنا او هناك ويبرم اتفاقيه
ويشكل لجان وحتى لو اتت لو اتى مراقبين
يعني من الخارج ام لكن عمليا
عدم وجود الثقه المراوغه ما اعتاد عليه
حقيقه الحوثيين في كل الهدن الذي عقدوها
من قبل حتى في حربهم مع علي عبد الله صالح
كانوا يخرجونها دوما فهم لا يعني اذا ما
وجد الفرصه لن يتوقفوا عن خرق اي هدنه
الثقه هنا الحقيقه منعدمه ولذلك لست
متفائل بالنسبه
للموضوع الاخر
موضوع ما تتحدثوا عن قضيه المفاوضات
المفاوضات ممكن الاطراف يذهبون الى طوله
المفاوضات لكن الاساس والخلفيه ان كلا
سيذهب مشروعه وبالتالي طالما ولم يتفق على
مرجعيه المفاوضات وخاصه بعد التصريحات
التي ذكرت
محمص ام اشكر تكرر التجربه السابقه لانهم
ما زالوا مصرين على عدم الاعتراف
بالمخرجات
واكدو وكررو طرفي الانقلاب وبالتالي ستكون
هناك مفاوضات شبه لا تنتهي الى لا شيء
شكرا لك محمد ناجي علاو من الرياض الناشط
السياسي وعضو الهيئه الوطنيه للرقابه على
تنفيذ مخرجات الحوار الوطني من لندن اشكر
الكاتب والبحث السياسي اليمني محمد جميح
واشكر ايضا من صنعاء كان معنا عبر الهاتف
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي عبد الوهاب
الشرث نهايه حلقتنا شكرا للمتابعه والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء
ه